monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'usagé du transport
public augmente dans les habitudes des
français
réponse essentielle aux enjeux
environnementaux
la fiabilité du transport public sa
continuité sont les conditions de son
développement mais surtout une exigence
pour tous ceux dont c'est le seul moyen
de transport trop souvent et en
particulier depuis sept jours la réalité
est tout autre car si le droit de grève
est un principe fondamental de notre
démocratie ce que nous respectons il est
malheureusement devenu le droit de
bloquer trouvez-vous tolérable que bus
métro et rer ter transilien soit à
l'arrêt ou presque des heures
interminables de galère la boule au
ventre
matin et soir sous la pluie et dans le
froid pour aller gagner leur vie et le
droit de payer leurs impôts pour ceux
qui n'ont pas la chance d'habiter à
proximité de leur lieu de travail
c'est inadmissible le droit de grève
n'est pas le droit de bloquer le pays
ne pensez vous pas que ce qui est
possible pour la télévision publique
devrait l'être pour les transports
publics
alors oui ou non ne pensez vous pas
qu'il est temps de prévoir le droit un
service garanti aux heures de pointe
concilier en droit de grève et droit
d'aller travailler pour notre économie
comme l'ont fait nos voisins européens
comme le sénat vous le propose avec la
ppl retailleau